[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight the war has been postponed it
turns out a day after the Islamic
Republic of Iran fired a salvo of
ballistic and cruise missiles into a
pair of military bases in Iraq we are
back from the brink this morning in a
live addressed to the nation which he no
doubt saw the president announced that
Iran's missiles had landed harmlessly no
American troops were killed in no Iraqis
either turned out to be a purely
symbolic bombing designed to stop rather
than start a larger war as the president
explained at least for now the
hostilities are over our great American
forces are prepared for anything
Iran appears to be standing down which
is a good thing for all parties
concerned and a very good thing for the
world a very good thing for the world
that's a big claim but in this case it
is not an overstatement for the past
five days all of us have had if nothing
else a chance to ruminate on what war
with Iran would mean for us here in the
United States and of course at best it
would be tragic very easily it could
become a catastrophe we've had time to
think about it we ought to be saying
prayers of thanks that it didn't happen
we came close and in fact we're still
close tonight thousands of American
troops remain stationed in Iraq and
that's a country we just learned that is
largely run by Iran think about that
after nearly 17 years of American
occupation Iran's most powerful military
leader a man that we considered a
terrorist was flying in and out of
Baghdad's Airport like he owned it
that's how comfortable he felt in Iraq a
place that we supposedly control now the
government of Iraq which need to be
reminded we created out of nothing and
then spent untold billions propping up
for more than a decade is taking Iran's
side in this dispute and demanding that
Americans leave the country so 17 years
trillions of American dollars more than
35,000 Americans killed or wounded you
probably know one and this is what we
get at the end in return another Iranian
proxies state that hates us it's
infuriating in fact it's worse than
infuriating it's immoral and the people
who let this happen should be punished
the Americans who let it happen
the casual recklessness they displayed
the utter incompetence it's all an
insult to the memory of the thousands of
Americans who died in Iraq this
mismanagement of that country by our
leads is one of the saddest things
America has ever done and yet suddenly
there may be an upside to all of this
sadness and it's this we can go now
Iraq's democratic elected government has
asked us to leave and we should leave
immediately remaining in Iraq increases
the power of bureaucrats and think tanks
in Washington it does do that and that's
why they're in favor of it but as the
last week has shown it imperils the
lives of Americans and for no good
reason we can't turn a rock into Belgium
we tried that it didn't work it's never
going to work we don't need their oil
anymore a lot has changed since 2003
we've got fracking now and so it's time
to go well but you can't just leave Iraq
scream - think tankers and the TV war
planners it's irresponsible they miss
the irony but you can't leave what she
you can here's how it's done how does
the United States get out of this
situation is there they get out that's
how they get out declare victory and
leave because I'll tell you this country
is just going to get further bogged down
there in a civil war over there wolf
there's nothing that we're going to be
able to do with the Civil War they are
in a major civil war and it's going to
go to Iran and it's going to go to other
countries they are in the midst of a
major civil war that was 2007 thirteen
years ago was good advice then we should
have taken it it's not too late let's do
it now